gras dur si vous deviez vous devenez une
femme qu'est ce quelle est la première
chose que vous feriez vous rêvez de
faire poids en tant que femme
toi t'es quoi me doigté sur toutes les
chaînes
j'étais moi j'ai fait un petit dossier
qu'on va déposer semaine prochaine
qu'est ce qui avait d'ailleurs alors
d'ultrasons c'est pas possible partout
qui d'affairé en bourse
[Musique]
[Rires]
sophie je vais vous placez pas partout
vous porteriez pour moi voilà merci
sophy
on a perdu benhaim on a perdu nous
regardait les deux ont regardé ce soir
face à face de fous rires
regardez mon manager
bizarrement je l'appelle par exemple les
éditeurs pour vous proposer des livres
les éditeurs de paris flammarion les
éditions de minuit
et quand je leur dis que s'est
poursuivie la nina au départ les mandats
alors amis
[Applaudissements]
je n'avais pas de trois temps la fatigue
en appel unitaire pour leur dire que je
travaille avec six villas du dakar tu
peux vous appeler bouzid ce n'est qu'à
ce moment-là il vous connaissent pas
vraiment en fait
[Applaudissements]
j'appelle les gens travaillent avec
jean-pierre bon compte mais vraiment
fait mal ce décret en fait ils pensent
que c'est un canular
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors si vous vous changer de sexe voilà
gras dur si vous deviez vous devenez une
femme qu'est ce quelle est la première
chose que vous feriez vous rêvez de
faire poids en tant que femme on fait
quoi le doigté
[Applaudissements]
mais tu m'as tu m'as demandé vêtements
voilà jeudi marriott même jour me et son
pied droit mais tout le monde aurait
fait ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je vous en supplie de diplômés sans
déconner emmanuelle boidron et qu'est ce
qui est drôle c'est pourquoi il ya un
courant loriette qui même si on le fait
on pour qu'elle cesse plus tard avec lui
et dans le calendrier des dieux du stade
où tu en très bonne mais pas vont
planter une fait tous les mois je suis
partout avril septembre à décembre
surtout pas la belle aurait fait une
danse endiablée agile et apparemment ils
ont commis l'irréparable on a retrouvé
la photo de leur fille on l'a regardé
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
l afrique quel côté ils en date
désobligeants
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
ces maillots des noms mais c'est elle et
pas du tout l est pas français je suis
folle essayé de le faire venir dans la
ga qu'au départ j'étais
[Musique]